there's a few things that I've learned
from the greats that have come before us
like the Tim ferrisses of the world and
people who have written about this in
the past and then there's a few things
that I've I would say developed on my
own I mean one of the biggest ways is to
just avoid reading comments when you see
things taking a turn for the negative so
like with that life dinner one I saw
some of the early quote tweets and
normally like you know for people that
don't know Twitter that well once you
start seeing quote tweets ticking up
like really fast alongside retweets you
know that there's some going down
like you gotta you're like oh okay
there's something happening and for me I
was like okay I stand by this I think
this is a great idea so I actually I
don't really care that's fine like quote
tweets are actually going to drive more
people to positively see the idea and
what it led to was tons of messages from
people that are like hey this is a great
idea I tried this like you
um that are gonna you know benefit from
it in some way so in any case I saw the
quotes you started to take up first
thing I did was I muted it so I muted
the conversation so that I would never
get a notification about it because for
me that's like okay out of sight out of
mind people can say whatever they want
about me fine I don't care and it was
funny like you messaged me and you were
like hey I hope you're good and I was
like I'm blissfully ignorant like I'm
waving around like I have no idea what's
going on it's totally fine so that's
number one
number two is
when someone writes something mean about
you who they don't know on the internet
that person is not a happy person I've
never met someone happy who has sat down
and written something extremely negative
about a person they don't know it just
doesn't happen that person has some sort
of pain or trauma or something in their
life that is leading them to react the
way that they are to this and
the most powerful thing I've ever read
on this is like you should default to
empathy when you see someone react that
way because there's something going on
in their life I just had a conversation
with a friend who had encountered this
who said that he shot a message to the
person that had sent the negative
thought and said like hey I hope you're
I hope you're all right you know I hope
everything's fine and the person replied
and said basically sorry you know my
wife my my wife recently got diagnosed
with cancer and so the way that you
worded this thing it really rubbed me
the wrong way and that's why I reacted
negatively and he said to me like you
know what a thing because I would have
replied really negatively to his
response but instead I defaulted to
empathy and realized that there was this
really challenging moment in this
person's life so that's the second one
the third one for me is like
a little bit more of like a
I don't know Flex or a slightly arrogant
version of this which is I had a moment
maybe like this might be like six months
ago now where someone said something
really mean and negative to me on the
internet and I was like in the bathroom
I read it and I was pretty bummed I was
like man this person doesn't know me and
then they said all these mean things
about me what is this and I came back
into my room and my son was in there uh
you know my beautiful wife was in bed I
like got into bed I have this nice house
and I was sitting there and I was like
huh yeah this is okay like you know like
here I am this person's probably sitting
in their mom's basement talking crap to
me on the internet and I'm like I'm
life's pretty good this is all right
like I can deal with it I can take the
heat like if I if I wasn't comfortable
taking the heat I should get out of the
kitchen
um so there's a little bit of just like
the man in the arena you know the Teddy
Roosevelt thing of when you're gonna put
yourself out there and you're gonna be
on in you know in the arena and on the
arena on that stage these things are
gonna happen you're going to draw some
of it people are going to be negative
and that's okay
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye